not an edge a is used for the turn at amino acid i. Here a could take on any
of the four possible directions in light of the configuration coding above. We can write these functions and then we
can define a difference in the number of a labelled turns on A and B latises from
index I to index J as delta N. Why would we do this? Well, it turns out that the
tetrahedral lattice has a very useful property. Let's focus in on this amino acid here. It doesn't matter which one
it is, but let's call it the E amino acid. We want to know how far apart the j amino acid will be. And all we have
are the edges along which the backbone steps. Starting from I note that a step
out from the center along a particular edge type call it a from this a lattice
site is exactly opposite and is undone by a step out along the edge a from the
b sites. So multiple steps along edge A from any A lattice site moves the
backbone away from the E amino acid and steps along edge type A from B sites
bring you back. So the distance between two amino acids I and J along the edge
type we will label A depend on the difference between steps made along A
edges from A sites and B sites. Since A and B necessarily alternate in the
protein backbone, this is captured by the minus1 to the K term. And this argument applies to other edge types as
well. So the distance between amino acids in the tetrahedral lattice steps can be calculated in the end by this
expression. But how do we get the Hamiltonian from this long equation for the total distance between the amino acids? There
is actually a onetoone correspondence between these distances in the tetrahedral lice steps and the uklidian
distance. And you can see I calculated some of the expressions for you already.
These distances can be used in calculating the energy of your configuration.
Depending on your purpose, you might dictate a cutoff distance below which you consider the pair to be interacting
or you might do something more complicated. It may not be obvious, but we're actually done with the mapping
stage by doing this. The states of the cubits indicate the turn, and the collection of turns dictates the
distance between any pair of amino acids. Pairs of various species of amino
acids have different interactions, some attractive, some repulsive. If you are using the configuration and distance to
merely determine if known amino acids interactions are on or off, the
strengths of these are wellnown. Not by me, but you can look them up on a table here like this one. So in summary, in
this example, the cubits are used to mark locations on a lattice which together form a chain of amino acids.
And by simulating how they bend and fold, we can hopefully find better outcomes in medical research. Now, we
skipped how to calculate a few terms of this Hamiltonian because they were hyper specific to this problem. While defining
directions on a lattice can be applied more generally.
Now once you have a general Hamiltonian, you are always going to want to translate that into poly operators which
are native to the quantum computer. That's what we'll discuss next.
Let's keep going. Now let's explore how to translate a system of subatomic particles into pi operators. Subatomic
particles are broken down into two categories. Bzons and firmians. Bzons
like photons or the higs obey a certain set of statistical rules and firmians like electrons or nutrinos obey another.
The key difference between them is that bzons are allowed to occupy the same state. There's no limit to how many
bzons can be in the ground state or any other excited state. Vermians on the other hand are selfish. They demand that
every single particle has its own quantum state. Bzons also have integer spins while firmians have half integer
spins like the spin 1/2 electron or more exotic spin three half particles. To
describe a system of particles, we need a description of their energy. Let's focus on firmians. We can start with the
Hamiltonian that is written in terms of what we call C operators. These are basically mathematical objects that
correspond to creating or annihilating a firmian from a state in the system.
These are often written as fi dagger and fi and a notation that we call second
quantization. Now fi dagger is the operator that creates a firmian in the state i. Fi is
the operator that destroys a firmian in the state i. But remember quantum computers usually operate in a cubit
basis with specific rules for representing firmianic systems. They do not inherently work in the language of
fionic operators. To bridge this gap, we need to map the second quantized notation into poly operators which
naturally correspond to quantum gates.
There are several such transformations for firmians. A common choice is the Jordan wingner transformation.
The bravi kvv and parody mappings are more recent for meionic encodings.
Bzonic operations on the other hand can be transformed by using the holdstein primacov transformation or directly
mapping the fox states to a subbasis of the available bzonic modes.
And there are other options for bzons as well. Other encodings are also actively being researched. But for now, we are
going to just focus on the Jordan Wner transform.
So why don't we just assign one cubit to represent each electron? Well, we can't.
Cubits are distinguishable and electrons are not. For instance, we can easily label and identify individual cubits on
any device, but the indistinguishability of electrons means we can't label them at all. we need to actually label
instead the operators according to occupied orbitals like 1 s 2s and 2p
instead of specific electrons. Thus we need to actually label the operators according to occupied orbitals like 1 s
2s and 2p instead of labeling specific electrons. So each cubit plays